[Music]
i can't wait forever i'm not that
patient i got too many things
[Music]
is
[Music]
i don't want to
[Music]
i'll share with you if you so kind of
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
would you disagree would you only see
that now right here's where we both are
and they're too afraid to turn around
and see how far
and see
how far
i can't wait forever
[Music]
[Music]
i
have tried my best
piled under
my strength
but the past i
can't see
when you
were here with me
[Music]
i'm still trapped beneath my
fears
and if you'd like to see my disgrace
[Music]
[Music]
call
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
a smile through
[Music]
with me
[Music]
my fears
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i'm
afraid to say
[Music]
the words you let us stray
i'm expected
to
pursue
a bond that i thought i was
[Music]
[Music]
i know it's been so
[Music]
i'm many trapped beneath my
fears
[Music]
face
wow
hello everybody
uh first of all before we get going with
today's stream i just want to say thank
you so much to everyone who has listened
to the music that i've written and that
was produced by jamie at horizon
productions it's the ep's always here um
and that's always the music that's in
the beginning but it was like the artist
unwrapped this year and i was like oh
it's so nice to know that people are
still listening to the music and i'm
very excited to get i'm really going to
get immersed into making more music next
year i'm going to put some things aside
so i can really focus on making the next
ep
it's going to be so exciting um but yeah
thank you so much to everyone who
listens and watches
watches listens all of the things it
means a lot to me i shared it on my
instagram and apparently my um
five-year-old oh she's six now oh i
should know this i think she might be
six my six-year-old niece is one of my
biggest fans
my um
my step-brother said that they play my
songs all the time which is so cute
because i like never see them either
because they live so far away so i was
like ah that's adorable um
but talking of music i thought i'd just
sing sing a little song for you i've
been trying to learn this evening i
don't know if anyone who plays animal
crossing but um i've been trying to
learn this evening a song um
that's in animal crossing uh it's like
captain's songs so i thought i'd give
you a little sing song i'll just say hi
to who's here say hi riser hi clay hi
sidney said hey no way jose or jose no
way jose isn't it 85 hey angel
hey kevin duggan
and thank you so much for being a
patreon recently nowhere day i really
really appreciate that and you're right
you're just in time for the patreon pen
pals christmas cards
very excited to get those out uh hey
john can't stan
yeah it's been loving today's style
thank you look at the back
it's so freaking wait is my hair in the
way
it's a lazy elephant
can you see it's a lazy elephant it's
from lazy oaf
i love it
it's a little bit pricey but i was like
i saw this and i was like i can't not
buy this look like a fashionable clown
but
anyway
hey solid
um
okay yeah so i'll try i'm probably gonna
butcher this but i'll sing it for you
probably another time but i was like
they can see
you know the progression of a song maybe
but yeah if you play animal crossing
you'll know this
so which one should i say
i done my best
[Music]
and sometimes i feel
feel like i've held
myself in too deep
so i turned over
a new
[Music]
[Music]
good night's sleep
[Music]
don't
cry about
[Music]
don't cry about
but dreams that don't come true today
sometimes you need to
find
another way
[Music]
so basically caffeine sings you loads of
like little songs when you go out on on
the boat islands and i thought they were
so cute and yeah so i've just been
learning it today and it's been it's
been really fun um but anyway
let's play games
that's a nice elephant
thanks john
hey solid
icah
right
it has been two weeks since we played
alan wake fingers crossed i can pick it
up nice and quickly but i was doing
really well last time we played do you
remember i was like becoming a pro so
just give me like half an hour and
hopefully we can get back to that
standard of gaming you know pro gaming
that's that's what you're all here to
see if you're here to see me you're here
to see programming because you know
you know that's what i do
but
we'll have fun no matter what
how was everyone's day
and week
to be honest this week has gone quite
fast
i have spent so much money on christmas
presents i need to stop is anyone like
that they've already got everyone's
christmas presents they keep seeing more
and they just want to spend so much
money but you can't because
you don't have that much money you need
to stop at some point
hey jeff
hi
you've been
hi jeff
but i'm gonna play i'm gonna play
previously on alan wake i'm haunted by
the law sheriff wake's running i'm
giving change are you seriously telling
me that writer just took out my deputies
the thriller i supposedly wrote is
coming true the genre of the story seems
to be shifting
it's turning into a horror story i was
told that alice oh yeah she wasn't
actually kidnapped that was a lie it's
all alive
we don't know where she is her reported
kidnapper was eaten up by the dark
presence before it attacked me
[Music]
alice
hartman i fell i had to give you a
sedative don't fight it you went through
another rough period what what are you
trying to kiss it's important that you
stay
we don't want you to have another
episode you're a patient at my clinic
have been for a while now wait what the
shock of your wife's death triggered a
mental illness yeah you're you're lying
you're suffering from various symptoms
of undifferentiated schizophrenia
bastard
it's okay
[Music]
man
so apparently he's got schizophrenia
whatever hartman had bumped in me was
making me numb
i felt like this was happening to
someone else someone i was watching on
television i couldn't think
couldn't focus
oh there were only empty sheets of paper
here no manuscript pages
it's very blown out outside jesus that's
a bright ass day uh let me know if you
want me to change the audio levels or
anything hey bergie
good evening good working day i'm
getting better now feeling calm
don't talk to me later i see you brought
your pet gorilla with you so sure i'm
calm okay i get the message loud and
clear
why right that's the spirit you're being
very brave alan i understand you're
confused i would be more concerned if
you weren't suspicious of me i don't
blame you for it big of you
now
why don't you come with me
we'll reacquaint you with my clinic and
go over everything you might have
forgotten
little walk and some fresh air
yes it will do you good
this corridor is for patients most of
them aren't here right now jack took
them out for a fishing trip
except for the ones who are particularly
vulnerable of course
night springs
there's an xbox game of that show that
we watch
they've got a nice view with a nice
little rocking chair jealous
have they made themselves a little map
of the area
huh
it's weird it's like they're planning an
escape
night springs this person loves night
springs what's there
got some crisps or something
i
i encourage creativity as a part of the
recovery process here at cauldron lake
lodge i specialize in treating artists i
bet you do oh and he's blended
i honestly believe we can get this thing
under control if we work together
this way alan
which way are you taking me
towards the wall oh it's an elevator
oh wow look at this big bear
are we gonna get to go out to the hedge
maze
yes
let me go to the hedge maze
i'm in i'm in
don't worry about me
now alan from past experience with you i
know i need to get right into the heart
of the matter as quickly as i can after
an episode
so i'm just going to say this
alice is dead
no
you're in a very vulnerable state until
you understand and accept this alice
drowned
and you couldn't face that
you're suffering from hallucinations
paranoid delusions
unusual thinking an obsession about
light and darkness a feeling that
everything revolves around you your
thoughts and dreams such a weird mind
has constructed waste of everything
in which your writings are affecting
reality
she has been kidnapped in supernatural
forces of darkness are trying to stop
you
we go this way alan i wasn't ready for
another shot so i went along with it he
had to be lying but under the influence
of the drug he had given me i had to
fight not to believe his words
it's all in your head
you've been making it up
apart from the tragic accident with your
wife no one has been killed
your delusions are just a manifestation
of your subconscious mind trying to
protect you from the too painful true
unless we fight the fantasy it will
return
i know the instinct is to resist me but
think about it doesn't this make far
more sense than the insane i mean yeah
it does but also i don't i don't want it
in your mind
by nature
we both know this everything can be
explained
logically
def doesn't like him
i don't want to like him but this does
seem extremely logical but yeah it can't
it can't be
oh sundown what time is it
jump can i jump can i imagine
hit on the sundial
can anybody read sandals is that three
beyond the shadow you settle for there's
a miracle illuminated in the memory of
dear friend
and a poet
okay why did you take me out here
look at the mountain
oh is this where she drowned he's like
this is where she drowned i
never get tired of this view
very inspiring isn't it cauldron lake
spread below us i could see mirror peak
on the other side of the lake
i thought i could make out the spot
where diver's isle had been when i
arrived with alice now there was nothing
but waves
oh it seems there's a storm coming
funny wow all there being a mention of
that in the weather that's a nice world
matter
this way follow me
alan what i'm telling you is good news
right now
every time you have a relapse it gets
more and more difficult to resurface
from the dark depths of your imagination
not surprising considering your
profession
imagination is what you work with
after all your nightmares this should
have an immense relief to you if it
doesn't why is that
because i'm lying oh now we get close
because you don't want to admit that
you're not well it's very natural for
you to think of me as your enemy does
anyone believe it is true hartman
obviously removed his own voice his
words echoed madly inside my head but i
can't i dug my nails into the palms of
my hands you need to work
[Music]
i want to go here's the entrance to the
office wing that's for staff only
you were impressed by my trophies when
you first arrived here
i do love to hunt the great outdoors
man what is that man doing sure it's
wonderful stuff pretty damn wonderful
yeah
he's like yeah scary yeah scary very
scary scary yeah your neck is scary you
should not bend like that
[Music]
[Laughter]
i'm a real bad dream mister you should
be afraid of me don't want to run into
me in the night that's for sure i don't
think i did not emerson mr wake is
confused enough as it is
yeah you'd like me to go away so you
won't be scared but you can't just
decide what kind of dream you have or
when you have it emerson
okay okay sorry sorry sorry
we're actually making some progress with
him i'm happy to say
he works on
videos
no kidding
[Music]
this way
[Music]
oh he's an artist
hello oh hello oh that's good i've
painted you
okay
i was just struck by inspiration a
couple of days ago dr hartman wanted me
to paint landscapes and that's what i
was doing but now i've been doing these
things a lot of them the images just
keep coming
likes them he has them in his office
yeah he's very proud of me he says i'm
getting much better i think i'm getting
better
okay that's good as long as you think
you're getting better that's all that
matters
but yeah it looks like he's drawing like
the
dark people you know
the people that we would kill with our
flashlight
what's that noise
it's like i'm standing on a dog squeaky
toy or something
hello
all right
not laughter there okay got it
uh
where was he taking me up there to the
patient's rooms or i don't know oh
coffee
is there something oh i could read this
the engaging new book by dr anil hartman
the author of the best-selling creative
flow his great breaking his
groundbreaking techniques engagement
therapy and the flow explained in his
own words now available in bookstores
around the country
[Music]
no
we ain't buying it i want to go stash
wait okay if i'm supposed to go in there
then hold on i'm looking up here first
i'm so annoying i'm sorry
whoa i was not used to that noise thank
you for following gay gaming with hybrid
thank you so much apartment had
mentioned that the power had been acting
up maybe that was the reason for the
generator and the work light on the
balcony
what worked like on the balcony wait i
think i was supposed to come here
afterwards but we're up here now so
screw game etiquette what's this qr code
anyone do it for me i i tried last time
and it didn't work so i'm not going to
waste my time again
this coffee over here
been a follower for years in your
youtube channel but not here lol well
that's good news cause i am going to be
moving to exclusive streaming on twitch
next year
exciting thinking
around seriously finally and there was
no key
um
but yeah more news on that
i guess early next year
so it's good to make the move
okay let's go where we're actually
supposed to be going
thank you thank you congratulations you
might have noticed the typewriter in
your room you've been writing as a part
of the therapy as soon as you feel up to
it you should continue
oh
there's a storm coming oh that was the
noise we could hear a storm
alban wipes this place off the face of
the earth
and these two are the anderson brothers
oden and tor they had a odin and thor
a heavy metal band in the 70s and 80s
in the first
they even adopted new first names to
complete the image of viking gods after
the band broke up they lived on a farm
nearby
in
they're well cared for tlc and all that
there's nothing more that can be done
i'm afraid that the rock and roll
lifestyle has left its mark
i mean they look to have lived to a
grand old age
i'm so sorry to cut this short for now
alan the power has been acting up i'd
better go check on it we'll continue
this soon
meanwhile when you feel up to it return
to your room and try to write it really
is for the best
don't you think why does everyone in
this game just want him to start writing
does he get any money out of him writing
i'd like to bash his head in with a
hammer oh he'd love to fish out our
secrets but he has no clue
he's not crazy enough
not crazy like a sunny
yeah
being crazy
who else could understand the world when
it's like this
it takes crazy to know crazy that's the
sanest thing i've heard in a while
you're all right tom hey we like him
don't we bro he's gotta go to the farm
the anderson farm
val
[Music]
you need to find the message here sonny
here's something for you gave me a rash
but i kept it safe from these bankers
why did he give you a wrench it was just
a piece of paper why did you keep it
my head was clearing up
or according to hartman i was sinking
back into the fantasy
i was convinced he was lying to me about
everything you have never not been
convinced the anderson's made more sense
okay
zane could feel the poems taking form
shaping things as he experimented he
imagined he could almost feel the power
surging through the keys of the
typewriter oh yeah
but there was fear too if not for his
young assistant emil he would have given
it up
but emil convinced him otherwise
he too had away with words okay yeah so
this is about the last the last writer
that died
because there's like a
a dark force that feeds off writers
maybe they just feed off artists hence
why all the artists there are in one
place and they're all a little bit crazy
or are they crazy you know oh the people
are crazy because this dark force is
like trying to use it no
well we have a stash of the special
stuff at the farm our own formula local
ingredients medicine clears your head
right up makes you remember like
moon beams on the brain
ah just notice leather patches on the
elbows
that's not very rock and roll
just lost his all baba yoga got to him
too the damn woods
welcome to cauldron lake lodge we're
here to give you the specialized help
you need however please observe the
following please ask friends and family
to schedule visits beforehand to ensure
they don't interfere with your therapy
and or periods of creativity also please
respect your fellow patients needs for
privacy and personal space especially
when they're engaged by their creative
processes i wish i had a place to go and
just be creative
be patient typically our patients have
long term creative problems and they
won't be solved overnight give yourself
permission to take the time you need
bear in mind that you're voluntarily
receiving treatment that has been
specifically tailored for you
engagement therapy and its system method
the flow works best when you're actively
engaged in shaping them if you have any
concerns please don't hesitate to voice
them
thank you enjoy your stay okay
uh can we go
back
up there because that's where the
generator was
yeah good thing he's not overreacting or
anything
well he's the boss what are you drinking
sleepy tea
the store is bound to make you i can't
remember what it is but it's like
different flavors
i can only focus on writing everything
else is a blur where's that coming from
i'm trapped in this cabin have been for
days but it's always dark outside oh my
editor is real
i saw her again she's not human
it's not human a dark presence is
wearing the old woman's face she was
covered in clinging shadows
there's a hole in her chest where her
heart should be
i think i've made a horrible mistake i
don't think i'm any closer to saving
alice it's been lying to me using me to
get the story at once and the story will
come true
what reflections do they use
because it doesn't it it never matches
the room does it
i don't think
there's a white
a white lamp no
anyway it doesn't matter um
okay we need to go get the key because
it's not it's not over here so it'll be
through here hartman wanted me to write
i knew
he was talking just then
[Music]
the white glare of the blank page in
front of me hurt my eyes
my hands began to shake uncontrollably
hey wake you stay here i'm gonna go see
what's up you just keep doing what
you're doing be cool okay
i didn't know what the chaos was all
about but it could be my only chance of
getting out of here where the hell did
he get a damn hammer oh my god
oh one of the old dudes is a
are you hammer so weak now
are we
can i see them where are they well
things are unraveling fast aren't
they oh
it's my store
hartman kept talking giving barry the
grand tour clearly proud of the place he
went on and on about his hunting
trophies and barry was impressed but he
was here on business he raised his voice
cut through the monologue hey hartman
where's al
hartman stopped in mid-sentence annoyed
at the interruption
he nodded at the hulking orderly
standing nearby
the man smiled and clapped a practice
hand on barry's shoulder okay
so
barry going to try and get it or will
come to try and get us
one of the two oh there they are
sinclair
the crazy old fart hit her hard if she
was one of hartman's goons she had it
coming i could get the key to the office
rise up in their name
hi
backstage is all yours tom
he had taken all my manuscript pages
that's where he'd been keeping them
uh
where
the markings on the tape said they were
recordings hartman had made at the
sessions with his patients
i saw alice's name on one of them for a
moment i couldn't breathe right
there's his portraits that he's been
doing
they're definitely the people we were
what the hell was that noise did you
hear that
clinic staff was standing outside the
lodge
i knew the man next to hartman he was
the kidnapper hartman had been playing
me all
just march out along
but no
he just ellen doesn't really sleep
and the work well
he's not writing
at all
he sits there for hours and just gets
more and more frustrated
and i can't talk to him yes tell me mrs
wake what would you say to him if he'd
listen
i don't know
i want to say
i look at you and it's not you
just
no
no
i've tried but
he's not listening
he's too deep in his own problems always
going on about something else
i'm so afraid i'm gonna lose him and
we're not even talking anymore he
doesn't let me in anymore
well if you can just get him here i'll
absolutely do my very best yeah but
doctor
you need to be careful with him
he's not just going to listen to you and
cooperate he's the most stubborn man
i've ever met well i'll be sure to bear
that in mind hearing her voice what she
was saying made me happy and sick and
guilty all at once yeah first of all i
recognize the words the phone call from
her it had been a cut up of this just a
recording
so she was not happy in their
relationship at all
she wanted out
or at least she she was trying to make
it work to be fair so
give her that hartman yes he didn't go
matt could see it in his eyes he quickly
lowered his own he had made a mess of it
and he knew it
the shame of failure was hard to bear he
hadn't expected wake to say he needed
more time
and he blurted out two days less than we
could ask for to show him who is in
charge but that wasn't part of hartman's
plan
okay
that was like way long ago in the past
before he came here
when he was trying to write and it
couldn't
there's nothing else in here is that
it's just that tape
yeah
okay so
for some reason the kidnapper dude was
there well i'm gonna do your crazy quack
ass that's right
come on
seriously do you have any idea how much
trouble
door
you okay
yeah i mean no
the cops found me at rose's trailer but
they didn't hassle me too much i'm
obviously a victim in this and i
demanded to be treated as such or else
i'd sue their asses what are you
speaking about
that that gave me a real hard time but i
had no clue where you were that guy's
crazy what did i just say hey let me go
then i get a call from hartman that son
of a [ __ ] who tells me you're here and
i should come pick you up but when i got
here two goons bobbered me and stuck me
in there okay what's what's with the
cutout i stole it from the diamond
[Music]
oops sorry
i didn't know it was going to be a
cutscene these are all the pages i had
on me
and more
alan please you're sliding back tell me
one more lie and i'll shoot you in the
face
ah well it was worth a shot
really wake come on
let's work together on this you have no
idea
shut up barry get out of here i'll catch
up with you get a car
oh ow let's just go
wait listen to me this is a mistake
don't you see together we can create
something absolutely wonderful with your
ability in mind
with his talent and your what
bullshitting skills yeah i mean to be
fair that is how it usually is
oh
okay
okay
do i just have to run through the
darkness
i'm very confused
anyone have any ideas what i'm supposed
to begin
into here
what the [ __ ] what about doing wrong out
the window
in a moment i had to find a way out up
here
is there like a secret hatch or
something
that i'm not seeing
[ __ ] it
[ __ ] bags uh
oh my god holdy are you [ __ ] me
did i actually say hold oh my god i was
literally just clicking er
oh that means i need to go upstairs then
it didn't say hold
what
well i'm kind of had you lot to tell me
to hold then
you can be my prompt
whoa
boom baby
[Music]
okay here we go
let's see if you touch anything it's
just like owie um
okay i guess i use how do i use the
flare again oh jesus
[Music]
[Music]
one sec
hartman knew we were oh we have twitter
he had no ambitions on that front and he
certainly didn't want to end up like
every artist he had worked with here
damaged in ways that were hard to
describe or worse
it was enough for hartman to maintain
creative control and provide direction
to be a producer that was what most of
these people were in need of anyway
of course suitable subjects were few and
far in between
okay
the
so
that's
alan wake with his binoculars when the
rider hit the water he ordered jack to
take the boat to him the spot was easy
to see in the dark even with all the
extra lights in the boat the flare
floated and kept burning even in the
water
jack turned the radial ladder as the
engine sputtered
the music
yeah they got him out of the water
but hartman chose to ignore it wake was
finally within his reach
[Music]
whole knee situation or am i good
um
no different not this place
oh [ __ ] she [ __ ]
this way there's a big ball coming
there's a big ball coming allen
big balls coming
ah
they've all got me
oh
oh my god the ball's in here
i'm here
oh thank god you have a flashlight love
you
is there anything for me to pick up
i'll be right there i'm just gonna have
a little look around little mosey
yeah also just in case there are some
flares or something
i know where you are i can see you
nothing down that way
okay we're good this is good i found the
car but the gate's locked you're gonna
have to go through the hedge maze over
there oh i knew it
we saw the hedgehog
oh oh thank you thank you thank you
thank you yes
oh god look at the house
the house is evil the house is wanted
the house is not a friend
oh
[Music]
here we go
that was me
okay
that wasn't even that scary i don't know
why i jumped sorry that's just a reflex
don't scare me [ __ ]
there you go that was your headphone
check headphone check
should i turn down the microphone let me
know
so trust emil oh god jesus [ __ ]
christ
thank you rock
i will not trust a meal
oh pretty tree a lot of leaves let's
pick up this
i stared at the viking paraphernalia
that littered the area surrounding an
unlikely slope oh my
complete with an god sound system with
all the trimmings including a dragon
it took a special kind of crazy to build
something like this in a remote field
when the sky split open with a deafening
boom and the music started blasting
it felt strangely appropriate
nice i can't wait till we go to their
farm it was a fun wasn't it yeah oh
that's gonna be so exciting
uh
it's this episode
is it i'm guessing it's because of the
valhalla that you're excited
rickshawlight
uh i think the volume is fine but maybe
not balanced enough on my end uh
balanced how like i'm too loud game's
too loud just let me know and i can i
can give it a tweak
okay let's get this
i
i hate when everything gets so wiggly
wiggly
i know they're come to me i can [ __ ]
hear him i can hear him
everywhere
not very good in the middle
i hate him
this game makes me scream i hate it
oh [ __ ] jesus
you know the bad thing about this as
well so i'm gonna keep on forgetting
where i've been
oh god just gonna keep on going
and hope i'm going the right way i think
i am
oh yes [ __ ] yeah [ __ ]
channel turn it off
[Music]
well you obviously forgot your pills
oh [ __ ] jesus [ __ ] birds
um
[Applause]
did i get him
okay
i can deal with one thing
yeah boy
yeah
[Music]
do
oh
hey ebb
hello chops and chocolates oh balls well
okay okay
anything hiding behind
yonder stone
[Music]
oh
this is basking
in the light
manuscript yes please
matt knew that wake was smarter than him
wake had more money a beautiful wife
everything and hartman said wake was
important that made him better than mott
but mott was calling the shots now he'd
expected wake to whimper and grovel but
instead he seemed willing to fight
montnui gotten under awake skin if only
mud actually had his wife
the thought made him shiver
yeah
[Music]
but you didn't you liar so the kidnapper
kidnapper is not
apparently rexella is very excited for
the song that is played at the farm
so that should be good times good times
ahead
got your [ __ ]
oh stop
stop
this
um
no we don't have a flag and ammo but we
do have flares
hello what do you want to say a meal
name emil made tom do it
so emil
wasn't that the last writer's um
assistant right
yeah i think
i think so
oh [ __ ]
a wheelbarrow it's the least of your
problems
yeah
yeah
mostly
yeah yeah the two old piratey dudes well
they made tom fight the duck in the past
okay
oh paige
hartman watched as wake's features
slackened the man was bullheaded no
doubt even lying on the bed he'd almost
broken hartman's nose this ah oh my god
i knew it's awesome
give him proper direction wake was
easily the most promising subject he had
had well since tom really
sleep well alan hartman whispered with a
smile
let me take care of you he sniffed hard
to clear his throbbing nose swallowed
blood and barely tasted it
so it was all just
people just using him there is a man
there oh yeah that's our friend hey
i don't think there'll be anything else
to pick up around
here you're alive
let's get out of here can you open this
gate
maybe
we'll try well i slammed it shut when
the nasty showed up and the key fits
kind of loose in the
don't worry about it
i'm great
oh great
what are you doing
oh [ __ ] off
go yeah yeah
oh [ __ ]
oh i hate when they come from behind you
you need to get like a good
place away something you need distance
that's what i'm trying to say
you put distance between yourself and
then hurry up barry
come on
[Music]
come on
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] bros
oh my god
and you can't really see through all
this fog so you've got to hope you're
doing something good
oh [ __ ] off your [ __ ] man i hate you i
hate you all right you got the key yes
let's [ __ ] go let's go let's go
don't even don't even
ow please tell me we're headed for the
nearest you're now leaving bright falls
come back soon sign we're going into the
anderson farm i knew you were gonna say
something like that you know what you
owe me big time for this when this is
through if we make it
you're gonna buy me a tanning bed as a
gift and i'm gonna live in it
wow i mean that won't be very good for
your skin though will it
but you know whatever makes you happy
we did just save her save our skin there
so
thank you for that
appreciate that
thanks
i tried
i'm crazy but that's fine
oh you got that right now you're barking
mad you are by far the craziest maybe
that's inevitable when you deal with
crazy stuff like this it helps this is
happening barry alice they never had
alice she's trapped in the darkness at
the bottom of the lake but she's not
dead ow how can you know that i know
barry i can't i know listen i can bring
her back i can find her there's
something special about this place the
lake it does something to the works of
art created here it makes them come true
but there's a catch the dark presence
whatever that thing is twists it to its
own ends that's why all of this is
happening it's using my manuscript to
take over everything ow i believe you it
happened to thomas zane before it
happened to the anderson i believe you
crazy or not you're not delusional weird
shit's going down that's a fact i'm on
board man i'm with you the andersons
knew about it but they were too far gone
to tell me with all the drugs they were
on but they wrote it down there's a
message somewhere at their farm bury we
just need to find it look out
that's gonna well down our route to the
park to the fire
god damn it out talk to me
i lost my gun in the crash oh great
barry was nowhere to be seen
you can't like preserve ammo in this
game because you try really hard and
then they're like
something big happens and you've lost
your gun again
you're okay
jeez it's good to hear your voice right
i was trying to get out of the car but
the ground gave way
what a drop don't worry your cutout is
fine
forget that
you're cut out
[Music]
there's no way you can climb down though
it's like a sheer wall
oh at least barry's okay that that makes
me feel good oh there's something moving
down here dog barry it's a taken you're
the player barry
yeah
barry are you all right
i'm great
thanks for subscribing alexi
[Music]
alexie sams
oh there it is there it is they were
already quite close
you're gonna have to find your way
around to the farm now i'll be waiting
yeah yeah yeah you do that don't worry
barry just wait for me okay
ow i'm not staying here it's suicide
that's fine i'm gonna go ahead and
secure the area you can catch up don't
worry about it i'm on the case
now he's rambo
this would turn into a disaster if i
didn't catch up with barry
i'm not going that way
go barry
barry
[Music]
rambo catch his breath
well
we've got some angry trees
oh [ __ ] off
oh god
why gang why
seriously
you put me with this dude
who runs about as fast as a penguin
and i have no light
and no guns
e
e
stop catching your breath
press the bloody button
is that ready nothing for me to pick up
around here
probably in there
okay [ __ ] it [ __ ] it [ __ ] it we're just
going in here
oh [ __ ] you little [ __ ] man
[Music]
oh god
[Music]
just to get a bloody piece of manuscript
when he stopped the car at the anderson
farm walter felt relieved oblivion was
close at hand
the brothers wouldn't miss a jar of
moonshine or two in the booby hatch but
then he saw the man on the porch and he
knew who it was
driving for his life and knowing it was
useless he didn't realize he was crying
until he couldn't see the road for the
tears
okay
thank you so much for the super chat
bricks alight
supposed to have a public for that oh
here it is it's very slow
can't stick around for the farm but i'll
watch the vod want to see your
expression when children of the under
god plays is that the song okay cool
i'll make sure that we listen to that
have a good time thank you for coming
anyway
uh
yeah i hope you enjoy the video when you
watch it have a good evening
if i don't bloody die on the way that is
nick oh there's coffee over
there let's go get the coffee
oh scheizer
i wish i could just like
what is this
oh my god
stop
i'm gonna die mate
oh dude
so annoying he's just running like whoa
just so slow i'm just a man
i can't run
oh god
i wish i had something at least like a
freaking flashlight some players would
be nice
do i have to go get that piece of paper
now
i'll take it a bit easy
here we go
okay
we've read that one okay cool but we've
got it now so
it's pretty fair the light does stay on
for quite a bit
i just wish we could find something
my mom let me hold the stick when i was
a kid
don't tell anyone what do you mean the
stick
no
come on come on dude do your thing do do
you dodgy dodgy thing i'm really bad
dodging in this game super janky
i wish i could like grab this and turn
it around that would be really useful
i need to get the coffee it's going to
annoy me
hello hello hello sam jones
long time no teammate
hey
[Music]
stay on
oh [ __ ] off
come get me i'm in the light you will
die
oh good
where
where [ __ ] off i hate i hate them all
i'm just going to stay in the same
bloody place here this is the only place
i've found with a bit of light
it's not fair
where are you
barrels
okay
spooky barrel come on spooky barrels
this could be
it's gonna end up hitting me
okay so if i just like hopefully i just
take this slow
it'll be okay because my health actually
does regenerate
so i just like should allow myself you
know
loads of bangs at once
i can take a couple ah [ __ ] off
kid be scared
let me hide behind trees
come on just keep going i don't even
give a [ __ ] anymore just go
to get through
okay
oh that's so cute sam you've got a puppy
what kind of puppy is it
i'm all good thanks just trying to
trying to get prepared for christmas
which is always fun
very stressful but it should be good
when the day comes
agent nightingale stared at the past
outrider the man was sleeping off one
hell of a night
nightingale felt a stab of envy at wakes
oblivion but he had a job to do he put
the gun to wake's head and almost became
a murderer his hands shook and his
throat felt tight and dry
biting his teeth he tried again to pull
the trigger he lost the nerve
wake stirred
nightingale would have to settle for an
arrest that was that really shady police
officer from last episode
okay
he had a job to do so he was supposed to
kill me i hope there'd still be a
working generator somewhere around here
to power up the old lights by the gate
oh yeah right here you just said that as
you were doing the generator you do
you do it
whoa dude what the hell you're just
faulty floorboards like that look after
yourself
we need you
uh
so how do we change the
oh maybe it's this
it's very wobbly
i could sense the movement in the woods
ahead facing the enemy without a weapon
was dangerous but i had no choice
well not a weapon got a flashlight at
least
trust no one in the dark i already know
this
i won't trust the mail don't worry
it's a golden doodle wow
what a what a mix
and yes i absolutely am i was saying the
beginning of the stream i've spent way
too much money on christmas presents you
just keep buying christmas buttons i
really should stop but
i just can't there's something wrong
with me
but yeah i do need to stop
it's just oh you know you just buy
things for people and then you're like
you see something else you're like oh
but they would laugh that you're like ah
maybe i'll just get myself out and then
this is
i'm
omega-3 fatty acids are good for your
heart
thanks game
teaching me things
come on one
oh god i'm going to die i just want to
pick up the [ __ ] battery
he ran right into them because he's just
i actually did
i i need to stop doing that too
but i found these lamps
i won't say much because i've bought a
lot of them for many different people um
and i absolutely love them and i bought
myself one as well uh because i think
they bring
and i think everyone i thought before
will love them
oh [ __ ] off your [ __ ] back okay fine
that's not gonna work okay i [ __ ] get
it it's not gonna work
oh it's just like how do i get them out
of the way like how how how how how do i
get them to go away
i don't have a gun or anything like how
how do i get them to leave
do i just need to get there faster
what the [ __ ] i could sense the movement
in the woods
okay mark said i could save some gifts
that would be your wise thing to do
that's a very
shut up stop it stop it
stop it
ah i hate you i hate you all screw you
just go just go just go
this is not going to work
oh there's more there's more there's
more
[ __ ] you
[ __ ] you
[ __ ] you
i wish i could just pick up their
weapons
come on there's a [ __ ] money up here
come on come on
this game [ __ ] drives me insane i
could sense the movement in the woods
ahead facing the enemy without a weapon
was dangerous but i had no choice
he goes so
slowly
so you're like trying to run but then
you can't really run so you're like you
have to turn around and try and do the
light thing to stop the people from
chasing you but then
and they come from every
everywhere
come on you little [ __ ] tits
let's go
all right don't get don't even try to
start that's not gonna [ __ ] work
so you make sure that these take
somewhere
over
the rainbow
way up high
there's the place
that you heard of
once
just go just go just go oh god yes [ __ ]
yes [ __ ] yes
oh my god oh my batteries i'm out of
batteries
duh
left or right
i'm scared
bad choice
a car was driving away from the farm
headed in the same general direction as
i was for all i knew it was barry caught
in the consequences of leaping before
looking
if you walk backwards while holding the
flashlight i'm not sure if you realize
that but people come from like
everywhere like so you'll end up getting
hit from behind and he walks like this
okay so if you're doing the flashlight
he walks like this like
not very fast
yeah but he only sprints for
a short amount and then he walks in this
extraordinary slow manner
very annoying until you stop sprinting
and then he let him get his little his
little wee breath back
what's this
a heavy duty okay
is that it i want more stuff i want a
gun
we can't all have what we want though
would be a nice place to camp
oh
car was heading for the cabin up ahead
it wasn't far if it was barry i would
see the damage soon
oh maybe not barry we'll find out
i'm not to waste my charge on you
spooky plank no you're okay the plank's
okay
oh
i'm trying to deliver each page to the
right time and place
i'm trying to show you how the story
goes
whoa
i had seen glimpses of the light before
i had seated in my dream
it was a strange spaceman or a diver in
a bulky suit he was the one who'd been
placing the pages on my path
space man or a diver
interesting
uh let's read this one the dark presence
followed the choreography laid out to it
in the manuscript growing stronger and
stronger moving like a storm from one
scene of destruction to the next but it
was still bound to follow the story and
chained to the dark place it came from
when the story reached the end at long
for it would finally be free
hmm
moving up the storm
bounce the story so it needs it needs
you to write the story it needs you to
write a certain ending
oh shoot shows
this is how i got through it before i
just went around it but
i don't think it's gonna work this time
hmm
[Music]
don't trust it
that's the heart of life
[Music]
let's go
hey
the key didn't like the stereo i just
the storm raged on as the anderson
brothers walked unsteadily away from the
clinic with the other patients in tow
knowing that this time they wouldn't
return
the darkness around them seed with
horrors but tor and odin were unafraid
their eyes glinted with guile they knew
every secret path and there was blood on
their hands they had fought these shades
before
okay so they're out are they gonna end
up coming to the farm then is that where
they're headed now
interesting
someone had left a gun behind now i had
a fighting chance of reaching the farm
thank you
we get the message
if you hear her
breathing in my ear again
okay we have a little bit of stuff now
which is nice um
four batteries we could do some more but
which one did we come from over here
this way
this way
let me just go up
probably not can we
can we
yes
oh there's something up there
is that
maybe not i don't think i can go up
there
it's got crows on it
maybe i stay away from the quotes maybe
the crows will alert the taking
i don't know probably not
[ __ ] up
with a passion
foreign
[ __ ] off your [ __ ] bag
you ain't worth my time sonny
chucking your little things at me
where do you think i am
a penguin
just get that one like one
ah damn it
ah you you can [ __ ] off at all
oh god if i die now oh god oh god i can
get in the [ __ ] light mate
oh yes
that was too close for comfort
but we made it
[Music]
i could see the car but there was no
sight at the driver
hallelujah indeed
jesus thanks mark
hello
hello byron anybody here
[Music]
i'm sorry
the front door was
locked that's fine
what about the basement
spooky basement
push
[Music]
i know you you were in jail the other
day
i went
to the farm again
for the moonshine you know
it makes you see
they're you're not gonna miss it
they're in the loony bin
my buddy
danny
i lost him
something's gone wrong with him
it's not him
like a real bad follow-up
to a real good movie
the best friends
suddenly the bad guy
oh
who wrote this
crap
anyway
his best friend hurt him i've killed him
i guess
oh
dude
where did he even go like did he
freaking jump out the window
wow
dude this was super human
hey is that door open now that door's
open now that door wasn't open before
oh
i've run through every possible course
in my head
if i continue like the dark presence
wants me to the story i'm writing won't
save alice it's a horror story and it's
going to kill her and me and everybody
in this town no one will survive
darkness will consume everything this is
what it's wanted all along it will be
free unstoppable it used alice to get to
me and dangled her in front of me to
keep me going it was never going to
release her i'm going to change this
i'll escape
can you buy a different enemy
i'm now the protagonist this feels like
a terrible risk but it's the only way to
save alice i'll be bound by the events
of the story just as much as anyone else
who's been woven into it the story must
stay true for the story
of it near escapes cliffhangers in a
horror story it can't be certain that
the hero will succeed or even survive he
almost has to die
i'll write my own escape into the story
next i need help
zane's going to be the one who will help
me i'll make it happen
good luck mate
good luck there buddy
[Music]
okay
can i use a phone
hello
barry
creepy best friend who is not a good
friend
big bear my lights are going crazy
oh that's
[Applause]
oh my god thank you so much
sorry fogger doggo thank you made it to
the stream after all
meps pro processing went great oh that's
good it's good to hear
i'm glad you you you're happy that you
um scared to scare the jesus salami
i didn't mean to
no that's fine
you know it all adds to the immersion so
it's all good uh i guess i jump out of
here then
the farm was still a good distance away
i'd need a car to get there fast
goodies down here though
oh so we're not actually at the farm
we're just at this
this is just a random house along the
way okay
poor little
just that
okay i mean it's better than nothing i
was just hoping for me a little bit
i'll leave with that
sydney was like that was going to get
clipped
yeah i probably will get clipped
anything out the front here that i
missed oh a manuscript yes please give
me
for a moment hartman considered
strangling the idiot mott was
mean-spirited but easily manipulated an
emotional infant who lived for his
approval wake by contrast was a far more
difficult subject mod had given him too
much leash in two days who knew what
could happen hartman would have to find
a way to rein him in and quickly
okay
yes i think we found everything
around here so let's just continue
anything in the in the party
you want to go for a pool mr wing
there's a toilet roll
oh this music just reminds me of arkham
asylum this is
so much i wonder which name came from he
was probably in trouble down at the farm
for a moment i felt bad for doubting him
after all i made it this far myself but
mary was barry
no poor barry
barry was barry
okay
barry has all the flares and stuff
though right he should be okay
you reckon asylum came first
i know it's supposed to wait is there a
farm or something something up there's
like a watchtower
oh and there's a house up here
uh with a little arrow saying this way
good things are this way
check it out
i just want to get all of the things
last episode i played i felt pretty good
about my ability to like
hoard stuff
yeah i wasn't i was quite frugal with my
ammunition i i played pretty well
hopefully we can do the same today we
shall find out
we already had the annoying bit of not
should we change cars yeah
okay
it's going a big range rover oh boy i've
already busted
um
[Music]
have we been here
no it's surely not
i'm gonna go up here anyway but i feel
like we've definitely been here
i signed with my pbnj back in the day oh
yeah all three of the asylum games
note i say three
were just amazing
hunting my fall
shotgun oh i don't know which one five
ammos or eleven i mean i do have more oh
but that's
oh that's a lot
why can't i have fries that's not fair
why don't you do this to me oh now
that's taunting me and i can't pick it
up again
now
okay 14. fine
well as i'm sure everyone's noticed that
storm we all felt coming is finally here
the boys at the weather service reckon
it'll last until morning at the very
least
pertaining to that let me uh read that
missing person's alert again the
sheriff's department's still looking for
a caucasian woman 30 years old slim and
blonde with blue eyes she may be lost in
the woods and it's possible she's been
injured in a car accident if you see her
please make sure you get her indoors and
call the sheriff it's bad weather to be
caught out in so if you see someone in
the area who maybe looks a little
confused
give him a hand all right
this is pat main on kbf fm hoping you're
all safe and warm tonight
i like him he's a nice man
oh
come on
oh [ __ ] jump jump [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ]
get in get in the car get in the car go
to the farm
oh i'm just kidding
oh [ __ ]
come on this is the lamb rover you
should be able to do everything
hey
i've got an achievement for the amount
of things i've killed in the car
get out of my way
my turf now
but
you
um
let's go through here
oh
did that all right i don't really know
how that looked really difficult but i
just threw a flare and ran for it okay
and
oh
that was weird
um
[Music]
we're getting there slowly but surely
slowly but surely
let me go up there
because i don't want to explore in this
game because i you know i don't want to
kill
more things but then i also do oh
because
i might find you know stuff that can
help me so it's a
toughy but here we go found something
else that's good
thank you very much
i appreciate that
[ __ ] it out
i gotta check i gotta turn down the
volume of these uh i will read in this
again
i don't even know what it was but you
know thank you whatever it was thank you
appreciate it
oh god get out his way
[Music]
thank you so much for following
everybody
um
thank you michael to be h and i'm ilk
for following me on the twitch
i appreciate that
i'd known the brothers used to be some
kind of rock stars but it hadn't really
sunk in until i saw the stage
oh
oh yeah the stage
[Music]
[Music]
oh awesome
okay
[Music]
[Music]
oh [ __ ] off where are they coming from
oh everywhere of course
[Music]
oh
[Music]
thank you thank you i appreciate that
[Music]
guys
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm saying like
i can't see anything whenever i like
please
[Music]
yes
[Music]
oh
and switch
oh god
okay okay oh my god my keys have come
off my keys
this is how intense i get i pull my keys
off the keyboard
let me just put this back on w's gone as
well
i'm breaking my [ __ ] keyboard
i'm breaking my keyboard
okay they're back on
let us continue
[Music]
i need to
reload
okay
[Music]
and then
don't catch your breath
again please please please i hate him
[Music]
the thing that begins with is
[Music]
i've already
[Music]
oh god [ __ ] jesus twice
they just come
come on
oh god
[Music]
[Music]
have you been reloading or not sir
[Music]
reload
they are trying to kill us
[Music]
is he putting the lights back on
[Music]
every night
[Music]
[Music]
oh my god too much [ __ ] is happening
[Music]
oh
[Music]
now now hurry the [ __ ] up
oh god it takes so long
the whole interaction
is
so deteriorating
[Music]
[Music]
do i start with the heavy duty one now
oh my
[Music]
god oh
[Music]
when you get in the concession of like
people just keeping on throwing things
at you you're just like oh my god
because you're not doing anything but
you think you've done something does
that make sense like you press reload
but it's been everything
right falls rock and roll capital of
america
oh my god i'm glad i have those grenades
hey ow save it out of the farm
uh
sure do you want to do a shotgun
now let's use the hunting rifle wait 13
ballots 25 and we do have much more here
but then maybe there's some in here oh
the shotgun ammo in here okay yeah we
shall keep these
uh
reloaded that's good
here and here
okay i think that's everything
i mean we've got a lot of stuff done
because we didn't use much of it
oh sorry i can't read my messages
they're not refreshing
i was going to the center because i was
hoping when the light got turned on i
would be right nearer so i could just
hop in it and get healed which did
happen once
to my credit it happened once
because once the light comes on if you
get in there your health goes straight
back up
and they can't follow you in there which
is nice
that was fun though i love the freaking
dragon on the stage that's so cool the
best seller no reason to worry your
cutouts good as new right where i left
it i'll come back for it once we have
the place secured
yeah that's been my biggest worry all
this time
we need to get this thing moved out of
the way yeah i mean this is as far as i
got before they ambushed me
[Music]
thanks for following lord zarnox
that was a bit delayed but you still
didn't i think alan wake here has
something to say uh what's that ow
i'm alan wake i'm always right about
everything and if i don't get my way
i'll sunk all day long i'm always
intense and moody it makes me very
attractive and mysterious
right now i'm just standing here because
i need my best friend barry to carry me
but that's okay i could just take him
for granted this game i think i see what
you did it was pretty good you want me
to do my imitation of barry wheeler no
i thought so
well we don't have a cut out with barry
so i mean it wouldn't be as good anyway
sorry for butchering your name lord lord
i don't know how else to say it that's
how i'm gonna say it
[Music]
i mean everyone calls me jagmanx
so i feel your pain
uh cool
now we can go in
all right i guess that's one way of
doing again down
do i explore is there anything around
here i mean
probably not but
might be something in here
oh paige up there
it's so easy to spot from afar which is
good
this light is amazing
as the deputies hauled waken wheeler
away agent nightingale eagerly examined
the stack of papers wake had been
carrying it was incomplete
a collection of random pages but there
was enough he saw his own name in there
among others his hands shook with
emotion
finally it was proof he had been right
all along
okay
so we're gonna get um
confirmation that we so need that we are
not crazy
and that hopefully we can still see my
wife
if our wife wants to be saved
what's that over there
hey that's one page that's another page
isn't
it stage
yeah let's go get it
nearly missed that one
looks like it was a part of the circuit
deputy mulligan tuned thornton's chatter
out he didn't think riders were
particularly useful people and a huge
manhunt for one stuck him as idiotic
certainly not worth the missed
opportunity for coffee and pie
it wasn't even clear what the man had
done except run from them at the trailer
park
mulligan knew he wasn't alone the
sheriff's patience with the fed was
running out
yay
we're not alone people are on our side
it's okay
okay let's go in
come on then barry take my cardboard cut
out let's go
wow
you look at that thing now they really
went all out with this fight oh wow
look at all this stuff they must have
done okay
oh sorry cut you off again
[Music]
that's what we keep seeing everywhere
tonight's episode
the dream of dreams that's by someone
else
he explores the endless dreamscape only
to be brought to us watch this with our
buddy
he's the guy dreaming us well not just
us he dreams everything all of this but
wait no i'm the one who's dreaming i'm
asleep is it
isn't this my dream
oh yeah
sure get real pal you're just another
dream
i'm a dream you're a dream the weirdo in
the diving suit is a dream hey the
waiter in the driving suit
i'm pretty sure i'm dreaming this well
maybe you're a
all i know is i'm going with the smart
guys and they say that's the guy doing
the dreaming right there what i don't
know what that means it means we keep
along with that lady
we make sure he has his clothes on when
he goes out in public
no chases where the monster is nipping
at his heels and he runs like crazy but
his legs don't seem to get him anywhere
none of that because if he wakes up in a
cold sweat
[Music]
yeah precisely
so we wait till he wants to move on keep
things nice and calm
hey something something's happening here
yeah what's that
what can't you hear that
oh god help us it's an alarm clock oh
it's you isn't it please man i got a
wife and kids please don't wait
the twilight zone
alan waits style
it's it's so annoying there's so many
things to pick up and i can't pick up
anything because i'm fouled
i hate that oh at least there's some
flares
there's a hunting rifle rifle i'm over i
don't have
you can't have both the shotgun and the
hunting rifle which is a shame
we know where to go if we need more ammo
let's keep going how are we going to do
this
oh there was a i just saw
a switch up there so there must be a way
to get that but there's other stairs
right here right here
oh you get called by your online name in
real lifestyle that's interesting i
think a few people call me jagman
um especially if like i knew them from
say for instance the guy i used to work
with before
where i work now um i i met him through
like working together on a youtube video
oh jeez where the hell did that even
come from why even hit me i don't even
know
um so that makes sense
uh
i think if if people like know me first
and then call me yagman i'm fine with it
but it does it does weird me out if
someone i've never met before it's just
like hey jagman i'm like oh my god who
are you
unless obviously it's in a space where
like
i know
like if i like i know i'm gonna meet
youtube people because that's different
because it's like youtube and that's
yeah like a youtube meetup or a youtube
event or something it's 1976 madness
reigns at the anderson farm
contrary to all logic the headiest
ingredient of their moonshine is
unfiltered water from cauldron lake
the andersons feel like gods odin can't
stop laughing
he contemplates cutting his eye out
tor runs across the field naked
hammer in his hand trying to catch
lightning their songs have power
something ancient is stirring in the
depths coming back oh that's so cool
wait
did they bring like this darkness out
through that music oh that would be
really interesting but yeah that's why
um odin only has one eye because he only
has one eye in the mythology doesn't he
because he gave up to like
learn like have more knowledge or
something
to try and stop um
ragnarok but you can't stop ragnarok
or at least have another hand
the viking boat looked imposing almost
like a battering ram
oh cool this is a set list
oh no they were going to go on tour
hello
[Music]
okay
this is good
let's get this ammo yeah
i don't think i can pick up
whatever's over here oh yeah
[Music]
you're a speedy boy speedy boy
uh let's go pick up them batteries
i think we can make it through here al
okay
what's in here
nothing
where is barry
i don't know
i heard him but i do not know where he
is
don't get caught by those
but at least
oh
foreign
[Music]
oh
that's weird
it wasn't even trying to attack me it's
just like
[Music]
okay
i will free you from your misery paul
castle oh there you are
wow those geezers had quite a production
going on oh you know what al if we make
it through this alive i'm gonna start
representing them yep sell this stuff
online maybe get a reality show going
release a new single
good luck with that pal
do it
out here okay i'm gonna take a closer
look at this stuff okay
door kick
yeah
don't know how that worked
be careful now
something's gonna happen
[Music]
oh
else want to jump out of me and be all
spooky
okay let's keep going that way
oh nice
oh this is the same light isn't it
heavy-duty lantern that's what i've got
right now
as you regular listeners know i tend to
work through the night but i'm not the
only one deputies mulligan and thornton
are taking a couple of moments off their
busy schedule to join me here in the
studio
boys how busy are you now deer fest is
almost here isn't it
i bet that keeps you in business
pretty busy yeah
actually pat we've been real busy with
other stuff
which concerns an ongoing investigation
we can't talk about that thornton
i wasn't gonna say anything
we got you know other audience to
things have seemed relatively peaceful
to me but people do tend to get a little
wild this time of year oh it's wild pat
it's pretty wild there's been all sorts
of trouble this year vandalism fighting
public disturbances
a lot of people gone missing too
yeah yeah it's pretty much the usual
stuff pat just you know a lot more
now
oh
it wasn't far now i wasn't worried about
trusting the ramblings of two burned out
geriatric wrecks
they had the goods
dear fest that sounds fun
if that's your kind of fan sitting here
then that's your forgotten burn i think
i'm staying away from anywhere where
grown men go crazy
oh i am so excited to like go back to
parties and stuff though
i just feel like it's still going to be
so many years away or i can do that kind
of stuff without being scared
[Music]
[Music]
oh
when one is gone more
more up here
you're never safe
no
just talking to myself ask myself
questions answering them
uh
yeah that wasn't so bad i thought it was
gonna be a lot worse
okay
hold on me we did this pat on the back
well done
okay
any pages any pages in here
no anything for me to take there is a
ladder
don't tell me it's where i'm supposed to
go because i don't i don't want to go
not yet
or is that just places for me to explore
isn't that one
is that where i just came from
this is good
that's a key
where are these keys for
silo open side our door for barry
is this it ah how is that you out there
buddy yeah it's me hang on
hello
hey let's go man where's it
oh it's good good thing i remembered you
i was just gonna go on ahead without you
sorry barry
i think we're gonna have to work
together to open this gate ow
hey i think that's the farm on the other
side of the field we're almost there
yeah this farm is a crazy place for
crazy people
we should feel right at home then
[Music]
oh teamwork come on one more gig let's
do this
[Music]
what does it say
old gods know the truth
yes or maybe they did
bring out the darkness like in the lake
or whatever the hell it is
the dark entity maybe they
their song was kind of summoned it
somehow
barry's a beast
the lights are out i guess we better
check the fuse box
asgard in the valley of my shadow
where's the fuse box do you know where
it is oh was it in there were you
showing me
oh no but there is just a random
coffee so i'll take that
oh what's this
what could i do there
is this something to do with the clock i
don't understand
the power downstairs was out but i was
sure i could fix that at the fuse box
oh so i can listen to that hell yeah
we've got any stage in here oh the house
looks so cool
such a cool farmhouse like you'd never
think a farmhouse is where two rockers
like metal heads
live making music singing in their
makeshift
um stage with a [ __ ] dragon that's so
cool
very very cool
definitely nothing in here come on out
let's get the lights on huh yeah i know
i'm just trying to find it
you know this place looks kind of lived
it i thought the andersons were on the
booby hatch
again
alice's screams rang in the stillness of
the night
i saw myself run toward the cabin
flashlight in my hand
i followed my past self i was an out of
body observer a time traveler in a crazy
drunken dream
this was the beginning the night alice
had disappeared the mystery of what had
happened during the missing week was
about to reveal itself
is this going to be the ending of this
episode
yeah i don't think they keep too close
an eye on them at the clinic they seem
to slip away a lot so they can get
wasted
kidding
those guys sound awesome
i think some bands actually did that at
one point at one point
or just like singing in a farmhouse and
having their own
stage that's pretty cool
[Music]
[Music]
even come from
[Music]
of course we need to find where it's
coming from that's the message the
anderson's talked about that's the whole
reason we're here
that's gotta be what's her face
cynthia weaver right
must be
[Music]
set free
[Music]
okay
okay
we need to find cynthia weaver we'll
stay here for the night and head back to
town as soon as it gets light
hey al lots of hours before dawn might
as well get some rest and by rest i mean
drunk yeah
no seriously because i know we don't get
along but we're gonna find her right
even though she's a crazy bastard i'm
gonna stick by you no matter whatever al
sure like a brother i'm a writer god
damn it correct
if i just wanted to i could write 10
books a year
and and they'd be the best books that
year no you couldn't that's right
but i could because i'm a writer what
what did they put in this stuff i feel
like my brain is coming out of my nose
i'm gonna get the recipe off of those
coots and be uh
a
booze millionaire
i just miss her barry
i just want her here with me
[Music]
it's gonna be okay
we're gonna make it okay
[Music]
[Music]
is he sleeping with his eyes open
okay he's not asleep
that's really creepy
is he okay
he's a ghost
damn it
what
wait is this when we get to see what
happened to her then
hey
[Music]
i'm coming it's all right i'm coming
it was a crazy drunken dream and yet it
was more than that it was the truth a
suppressed memory unearthed by the
anderson's moonshine
i was there an out-of-body observer this
was the night allison [ __ ] cool idea
the night alice had disappeared
i had a chance to find out what had
happened i remembered being surprised to
see the cabin dark alice would have
never turned the lights off
alice alice
i remember thinking i caught a glimpse
of her form underwater sinking into the
darkness
diving after her was the last vague
memory i had of that night
after that the next thing i could
remember was waking up behind the wheel
of the crash car and finding the first
pages of the manuscript
i couldn't find her in all that
blackness i must have thought she
drowned
alice jagger had alice and so she had me
alice
maybe she's inside
alice yes
there's no one in the window
the dark presence had touched me she had
dug her nails into my brain and used me
made me her puppet
she must be here somewhere
maybe upstairs in this study alice yes
that's where she is what's that voice
actually there when we were doing this
you laughed the whole thing together and
put it behind you no i didn't this voice
was it was just you would you did do all
this stuff though
she's not here
you were foolish to think so
no she's dead she drowned
no no no
it's your fault your wife is dead you
are guilty
all she wanted was to help you right
you killed her
oh hush there's still hope
cauldron lake is a special place
here you have the power to change things
she wanted you to write i will tell you
what to do
that's her
you can write her back the story will
come true
and all will be well again
she had alice and the manuscript was the
ransom for her
yes
all right
i'll fix it
i'll bring her back
uh
i wrote it
i remembered it all now
in the dark i'd written for days a week
almost a complete manuscript of a novel
entitled departure jagger had been my
editor whispering in my ear making sure
that the unfolding story would make her
more and more powerful i thought i was
saving alice
even with the cobwebs she put in my head
some part of me had been aware enough to
write my escape into the story to bring
a light into the cabin to release me
before i could finish
to interrupt the horror story before the
ending where darkness consumed
everything and everyone
zane was weak and far away
but i had written him into the story and
his light had been enough to set me free
she stole the skin of my barber a long
time ago she looks so old
she looks so old
so that's the old writer and barbara the
old woman is the person that he loved
confused the darkness
my mind consumed by darkness and fear
all i could do was to escape
the weak spin of the cabin had taken its
toll i was barely conscious and fading
fast
[Music]
but he had managed to weaken the dark
presence kept me safe that night
i wrote it it's my fault
that's right james joyce it's your fault
and you're gonna pay for it
i was like not a friend
[Music]
[Music]
okay that's the end of episode four
everybody
no thank you
ah that was really good um if i remember
rightly we have two more episodes to go
i think i think there's six episodes
over all of alan week so yeah two more
episodes to go very exciting i am
absolutely loving playing this game with
you even though the controls are a pain
in the eyes i get so angry it's so
annoying but
it is a really good game
and i saw someone came in and they said
uh james james of ofc james of course
said um they've only played three hours
of the game they're like it looks like
it goes places yes this game is so
interesting what the hell who came up
with
you know two old rockers who live in a
shed and are like musicians are playing
a stage that's cool in itself but then
no also they like
they act as if they are odin and thor
and they sing about the
asgard and like norse gods and stuff and
they possibly are the reason why this
dark
magic essence whatever the hell it is
came to being or at least had a hand in
it that's so freaking weird like who
would have seen that coming uh it's yeah
very cool game i love that the idea of
being like in an out-of-body experience
i would love to see a game try and do
that now uh because it was very janky um
and him kind of popping it in and out
was
it didn't really do it for me but i love
the idea that i love the premise it's
very cool very interesting uh because
you do dream like that as well i mean if
anyone here remembers your dreams
i often remember my dreams and it's
always third person i always feel like
i'm kind of floating i mean maybe
sometimes it's first person but a lot of
the time it is third person and it's
it'd be very interesting to play a game
like that
where you're like an observer not for
the full game but for a part of it like
that would be very interesting um
anyway
i have not played deadly premonitions no
i have not you're poor keyboard i know
i can't believe i've
like ripped off the bloody keys i'm just
i'm going like ah
they just they just came off on my
fingers i was like oh crap please put
them back on
ah that was interesting
uh you didn't die that much you don't
think i did okay thank you
thanks sidney there yes went brutal on
the keys i had to go brutal so brutal on
the keys
ah but yeah that was so that was a fun
episode i can see why rick's alike was
like oh it's this episode so much
happened in this episode it was very fun
it was very good and i feel like we're
you're finally
starting to understand actually what is
going on because for a while i was
extremely confused at the beginning of
this i was like don't tell me he's just
crazy
and then no luckily he wasn't there's
actually stuff going on um but yeah very
interesting very excited for next week
so
anyway thank you so much for watching um
i should also say that i have a new song
coming out on uh fingers crossed it
should be december the 13th uh so look
out for that it's another music video
made in unreal engine uh using the
sprites that you saw me do last week so
should be releasing on december the 13th
uh on all music streaming platforms and
on youtube for the music video of course
and it is produced by jamie at horizon
productions um
same as this
this one here
uh but yeah very
very excited are you a magician are you
saying that i really love you because of
the jumper i mean
sure i could be i could be a magician
i don't know what i would do but i could
learn a trick or two maybe
possibly probably not
i know you can't for stream but once the
game is complete as the songs and story
relate you should definitely listen to
the soundtrack it's so good okay yeah
yeah i will do that i don't know if you
saw my instagram stories but my
top you know the spotify and rapt thing
spotify rap thing um my top uh genres
number one was soundtrack because i just
listened to soundtrack all the time
witcher soundtrack oblivion soundtrack
lord of the rings soundtrack i just love
soundtracks i can't believe it was
number one genre i was like oh i listen
to them way more than i thought i think
it's just because they don't distract
you when you're working and stuff so
but yeah this would be a good soundtrack
to listen to so thank you
my top was soundtracks too
you get it james you get it james it is
it's just really nice to listen to it it
doesn't distract you and it it makes you
feel feelings like you know if you
listen to like say if i listen to that
lord of the rings soundtrack and just
like i feel happy and nostalgic and just
like content
um and especially when i was
playing the witcher a lot i've stopped
now because i don't want it to end which
is stupid i need to just keep playing it
but i don't want it to end but i need to
finish
i have this with i just don't like
goodbyes i'm very bad
goodbyes um but anyway when i was
playing witcher a lot when i was working
i wanted to play the witcher so i would
just listen to the witcher soundtrack so
that was you know that was at least
something
anyway i'm gonna go now so i'm gonna say
hello oh sorry goodbye to who i can see
in the chat um don't forget to follow
subscribe do all of the wonderful things
and then you can see when i am streaming
next i'll also put a link to the uh
discord just in case nobody is in or any
yeah that anyone wants to be in the
discord uh
words
i'm good at them
uh discord
join it
if you want
no pressure i know most of you already
in there anyway
and i will see you next thursday at 8 30
pm
gmt
so good night sam jones good night mark
druid good night abe196
good night moss good night
james of course good night mantas
goodbye death 157
goodbye oh and sorry moss i saw you said
hi
i'm sorry you came as i was leaving but
hopefully maybe you can catch another
stream but thanks for coming anyway
um goodbye
no way jose
and thanks again for being uh the newest
patreon really appreciate that
uh goodbye sam jones today i already say
that goodbye sam jones
i think that might be it good goodbye i
really love you
that name
it's so cute
okay
i think that's everyone i can see
goodbye to anyone who i have not said
goodbye to and goodbye to anyone who is
watching but isn't in the chat as always
i really appreciate you being here as
well so i will see you
next thursday have a good evening